de la course à pied à présent et le
compte à rebours est lancé dans moins de
deux semaines le 18 mars
12600 participants vont prendre le
départ de l'éco-trail de Paris au
programme de cette 16e édition de la
Marche Nordique et des trails et preuve
fort bien sûr c'est le 80 km et qui
partira de l'île de loisirs de 50 ans en
Yvelines avec le final un final
classique au premier étage de la Tour
Eiffel et pour en parler un invité est
avec nous en visio c'est Hervé Parda et
bonsoir Oui bonsoir alors vous êtes l'un
des organisateurs alors plus de 12000
participants pour cette édition de
l'écho trail de Paris est-ce que vous
êtes satisfait de ce nombre d'inscrits
oui très satisfait donc on va être
proche des 13000 coureurs inscrits donc
après une année des années covid un peu
compliquées nous sommes très satisfaits
de ce retour à la normale et on va donc
accueillir 13000 coureurs donc notamment
à peu près 85 % sont des francilien
alors 85 % de Franciliens 12000 coureurs
au total sur les preuves phare le 80 km
avec je le disais des parts de l'île de
loisirs le final au premier étage de la
Tour Eiffel combien de combien
d'inscrits sur cette épreuve donc sur
l'épreuve du 80 km on attend environ
2500 participants en effet qui vont
prendre donc le départ le samedi 18 mars
avec c'est arrivé exceptionnel au
premier étage de la Tour Eiffel après
avoir traversé donc trois départements
avec les Yvelines les Hauts-de-Seine et
Paris on peut dire que c'est l'épreuve
reine de l'écoterais même si on a
compris à plusieurs épreuves au
programme mais ce 80 km c'est quand même
on va dire la figure de proue de l'éco
trail de Paris
alors c'est vraiment en effet l'épreuve
reine n'est pas phares pour les adeptes
de trail parce que les coterais de Paris
c'est vraiment une invitation justement
à découvrir à redécouvrir le patrimoine
de la région Île-de-France et le 80 km
justement va faire traverser les
sublimes et Hauts-de-Seine et Paris et
ils vont traverser des nombreux sites
qui sont emblématiques de la région
Île-de-France avec l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on va passer
devant le vélodrome ensuite on on va
s'attaquer à Buc donc le château de Buc
il y aura un ravitaillement on va
rejoindre ensuite les forêts
franciliennes de l'Ouest franciliens
donc avec la forêt de Manial de
Versailles ensuite Meudon fausse repose
le domaine national de Saint-Cloud et
puis on va longer les pour terminer les
10 derniers kilomètres sur les le nom
des pieds de scènes pour rallier le
premier étage de la Tour Eiffel c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment un magnifique
parcours pour mettre en avant donc tout
ce patrimoine de l'ouest francilien
patrimoine donc naturel historique et
culturel on voit l'image un premier
étage de la Tour Eiffel après c'est 80
km avec des jambes coupées voilà qui a
tendance à couper les jambes des des
coureurs une épreuve très difficile
nickel oui qu'est-ce qui fait la force
de l'écoterelle à votre avis
la force de l'écotrail donc c'est déjà
c'est en effet ce que je disais c'est
vraiment la découverte et la
redécouverte de la région Île-de-France
et pas juste une course à pied c'est
vraiment c'est mettre en avant tout ce
patrimoine assez exceptionnel que l'on a
dans l'ouest francilien notamment avec
dans les Yvelines parce qu'on a deux
départs exceptionnels donc on a 80 km en
effet qui part de l'île de loisirs mais
on a également le 45 km qui est une
épreuve tard et qui parle du jardin du
château de Versailles le long du grand
canal donc c'est vraiment des des
paysages
somptueux on va faire découvrir à ses
coureurs de trail et que ça soit sur le
81 de 45 le 30 km le 18 et le 10 km
c'est vraiment un réel plaisir de venir
participer à l'écotrail Paris sans
compter
pour en parler aussi
et finalement tout le monde peut
participer à l'écotrail si on voit
toutes les distances
alors si on voit toutes les distances en
effet
on les adepte de course longues ils vont
faire le 80 ceux qui sont plutôt
marathoniens vont plutôt s'attaquer aux
45 km
après on a on a un effet une épreuve un
peu intermédiaire qui est 30 km il y a
le 18 km qui existe depuis 2008 depuis
sa création et on a sorti donc il y a
maintenant deux ans le 10 km donc une
épreuve finalement qui est pour la
découverte de la course nature et ça et
ça c'est intéressant aussi pour pour
venir découvrir déjà ce que c'est qu'un
trail et pour maintenant certains déjà
certains coureurs ont fait 18 ils
reviennent l'année d'après pour faire le
30 et jusqu'au 80 km donc c'est ça qui
est assez sympa
et quel est le profil des participants à
l'écoterais leur voulait dire selon les
distances peut-être des profils qui
diffèrent 80 km on imagine ça demande
beaucoup beaucoup d'entraînements on
croise d'ailleurs assez souvent des des
figures assez connues du trek francilien
j'ai oublié son nom mais il y a
casquette verte notamment qui revient à
chaque année en tout cas il est
reconnaissable par cette casquette verte
qu'il porte c'est quoi le profil de
découvrir de l'écotrail
le profil des coins les cochrame mais
c'est ce que je disais par rapport au
nom de déjà la participation des
Franciliens donc c'est 85% de coureurs
franciliens et dans ces coureurs donc on
a 30% de femmes et et 70% d'hommes donc
qui sont répartis plutôt plus d'hommes
on va dire sur les parcours longs comme
le 80 km et il y a plus de femmes sur
les marchandiques et la répartition en
effet elle elle a lieu en effet sur
on va dire ça la moyenne d'âge elle est
à peu près de 40 ans la moyenne d'âge
sur l'ensemble des courses et on a aussi
des fidèles sur cette course les
cauterelle on l'a fait bien Parmentier
par exemple qui habite à montim retenus
qui a fait toutes les éditions sauf une
je crois parce qu'il avait un autre
trait à ce moment-là il devrait revenir
à nouveau cette année et il y a
également aussi des Dialo aussi un ini
montant qui court quant à lui un pied nu
pieds nus il est parti pieds nus de
l'île de loisirs de Saint-Quentin de
vignes pour aller jusqu'à la tour Eiffel
c'était il y a deux ans je crois et il a
il a fait trois quatre fois
on l'imagine qui se développe d'année en
année vous avez cette impression là
alors on a développé donc moi je suis
fondateur de l'événement donc c'était en
2008 qu'on avait fait la première
édition c'était un 16 février il faisait
très froid mais ça ça a marché dès la
première édition
et depuis c'est assez développé parce
que je rappelle les chiffres on était à
peine 900 inscrits sur le 80 km la
première édition et maintenant on est on
est proche de de 3000 coureurs quand
même donc c'est c'est vraiment
impressionnant de voir cette
cette comment dire c'est pouvoir qui se
sont inscrits de plus en plus nombreux
chaque année alors connu quelques
quelques coins des Yvelines peut-être
une dernière question qu'est-ce qu'on
peut vous souhaiter pour cette nouvelle
édition
alors pour cette nouvelle édition
on peut on peut nous souhaiter un
finalement une belle météo ce serait
sympa un peu un peu de soleil et pas
trop froid pour une fois on va vous
souhaiter cette météo merci Hervé d'être
venu en parler dans cette édition du 7 8
on rappelle la date un 18 mars pour les
coterais de Paris avec un 80 km qui
partira et depuis l'île de loisirs de 50
ans en Yvelines un deuxième parcours
dans les Yvelines de 45 km également au
départ de Versailles merci d'avoir été
avec